So what are the students going to be doing when they meet up once a week?
They're going to be presenting their lessons learned,
and they're going to be presenting in front of their entire peers.
Now, you'll be sitting in the back of the room, both the facilitators and the mentors,
and critiquing what they've learned.
And as they present, remember, you've been reading their LaunchPad Central blog posts,
so you kind of know who they've been talking to.
So this is almost a summary,
but you will be giving them comments.
In the meantime, the students, instead of just sitting there and doing their email,
who are not presenting, actually have a shared Google Doc
and they're doing peer grading of their peers, of their presentations,
and giving them feedback as well.
And what the students are doing outside the classroom are 10 to 15 hours
of customer discovery, and they're spending at least an hour a week
blogging what they've learned, and they're using the LaunchPad Central tool to do that.
And they're watching the lectures online on the Udacity site.
What you're doing as facilitators and coaches is you're answering questions
about the lectures, and you're critiquing team presentations.
And what the teaching team is using is, you're using a shared Google Doc,
sitting in the back of the room, grading, while the students
are using their peer grading doc, which is very separate from yours.
So they don't get to see your grades, and you get to see theirs later.
But now the teaching team is actually writing down
what you think of each one of the teams.
And again, in between the weeks your job is to review and comment
on the team's customer discovery narrative using the LaunchPad Central tool.